one of the things that you've done very
successfully in addition to uh
do so well in the music world is you
have your own clothing line yes sir
sean john sean john in a store near you
it's out there
and shameless plug well it it
you know i've seen this stuff and this
stuff looks cool and i was thinking that
the other day i was thinking to myself i
could use a little help
[Music]
and i asked you if you would stop by
you did this yesterday you were very
kind if you would stop by and give me a
little fashion advice
and maybe bring some of your clothing
with you
this man was very kind he came by and he
did his best
i tried to help me make the scene uh
let's take a look right now we filmed
the whole thing it's
[Music]
p welcome to my dressing room good to
have you here you can call me c if you
want
uh you got some clothes you got some
some fine clothes
tell me what do you think about what i'm
wearing now this is what i tend to wear
i think i need help you think i'm pretty
much good the way i am is this lint
balls
yeah i got little lint balls is that bad
that's not good
what do you think is this sweater
cleaner uh i had the sweater
i got it in college not good
this should go the sweater should go
well let's get your ass in something
nice come on let's
we're gonna have to change the look
let's get my ass into something good is
what you're saying
okay we have to update you baby boy come
on okay
[Music]
you gotta be kidding me i'm talking
about this is your stuff i mean i mean
i know it's my stuff it looks beautiful
don't you think this looks pretty
fly but yeah
i mean good god man this socks socks
the socks are comfortable the baby baby
baby it's color coordination it's coming
to socks it throws it all off so i just
gotta lose stuff it all off and it's
like
okay okay it may be an odor because i've
got a molasses
get a tan good god man i was sickly
i was just sickly as a child now listen
what do you think of this though huh i
mean do you wear it like that
i have arrived
[Music]
[Applause]
how you doing there
[Applause]
is a cover good for me
[Music]
do you think i should stand like this oh
oh no don't do that
okay how about hands in the back of the
pockets
sort of accentuate the ass a little bit
why are you talking to me like that
okay okay so just so get the
something about your accent i don't know
i'm trying to just you know
make the clothes look better so don't
talk about my ass that's not your first
advice
leave my ass out of the conversation you
keep on talking about it
[Applause]
break it down do you think on the show i
could wear this
playboy you can wear that out every day
every day every day
yes every day
this is nice
yes go ahead with your bad stuff look at
that and
i can do this move remember prince in
the revolution he used to do this move
you know something what you got to go
out there you got to show people your
new style
my news reinvented yourself i'm gonna go
show them right now
this is a makeover for you conan this is
it this is the look you've been looking
for
i'm going out i'm showing the world you
go do that thank you p okay
[Music]
[Applause]
you